CROSBY'S START AND RUST AND  LI
TURNOVER BY MALKIN.
NOW IT'S VA TRANO AND HE KEEPS !
>> Kenny: PETTERSSON FIRES AND
HEINEN SCORES!
UP IN THE AIR.
CARTER KNOCKS IT OUT OF MID AIR.
IT'S GUENTZEL ON CROSS-ICE PASS
ANS WIDE OPEN IN BEHIND THE
NET.
TWO RANGERS BELOW THE GOAL LIN
>>: IT STARTED FROM LOW TO
LOW TO HIGH.
>> Kenny: KEPTMcHUGH,
WAYNORED THREE QUICK GOALS.
THEY WON THE GAME 5-3.
>> E E OR FOUR
OF THOSE UNLESS SOMEONE DECIDES
TO CHECK ONE OR GIVE IT TO TOM
>> Kenny: STROME FOR ZIBANEJAD
AND HE SCORES!
IT TOO
A QUICK LITTLE CROSS-CHECK.
REFEREE DID NOT CALL I SOMETHIN
LIKE THAT, OKAY..
LAST YEAR'Y ADAM
FOX. ITS LOOK LIKE
A LITTLE BIT MORE TRAFFIC IN
ZIBANEJAD!
STOP, REBOUND, SCORE!
CHRIS KREIDER KNOCKS IT IN ON
THE POWER PLAYY DOMINGUE.
A LITTLE SNI MALKIN CHASED AND
SCORES THERE.
MALKIN IS MONEY IN THOSE
SITUATIONS ON THE BREAK-AWAYE P.
PENGUINS LEAD THE SERIES
IT HIT OFF DOMINGUE AND CROS
BAD GOAL GIVEN UP BY LOUIE
RACING AFTER INALTY APPEAR
2-0.